like Samuel leaves here and I've seen so
many people recently who's been asking
me which is the best strategy and
they're unsure of where to start maybe
they've been read lots of books they've
been talking to lots of people they've
been searching on my forearms and
they're thinking what's the best
strategy to start so if you're unsure
confused about that then this video is
for you so stay tuned so for me
personally to ask which is the best
strategy it's such a big question and it
depends so much on your personal
circumstances so like right now on
buying big development properties I've
just bought a castle but I wouldn't
necessarily recommend everybody does
that so it depends on what your outcome
is it depends on where you're starting
the stuff that I've done I've got
experience in it's quite vast hmo's
single at vitae let's flats commercial
service accommodation buying
refurbishing refinancing sourcing
packaging flipping there's a real real
vast amount of stuff and also those are
strategies but also the techniques as
well so that would involve raising for
announced joint ventures tax structure
business set up negotiating below market
value deals joint there's a whole bunch
of strategies techniques so I can
understand why for some people starting
out it is really confusing my advice
would be if I was you would be to just
choose one choose one strategy one thing
and then just do that and focus on that
because what you'll find is you're
getting your first deal is always the
hardest so when you win you've got that
first deal and you've done it you're
gonna have such a confidence boost you
can feel so happy and then you'll be
able to just rinse and repeat the most
dangerous place to be in is standing
still because at least if you're moving
at least if you're out viewing
properties and you're doing stuff and
your point offers in then you can be
fluid and you can move around but if you
just standing still confused like a
rabbit caught in headlights you'll never
get anywhere so my advice would be
choose warm strategy fix your eyes on
that and that alone and people are gonna
tell you you know no no don't do that do
this but that's always gonna happen no
matter what strategy you choose no one's
gonna say that's the perfect strategy
there's always really people saying this
is better this is better but you got to
choose one strategy one thing
focus on it let that be your mountain
set out ingrained in your brain to
achieve it and don't focus on anything
else that is your mountain and
rown says this is my mountain and I'm
getting to the top no no this is my
Mountain you're either gonna see me dead
at the side or waving from the top
because I'm not turning back and when
you have that kind of focus and that
dogged determination on one single
strategy
you're gonna achieve it and then when
you've done that then you can assess you
plan it you do it you review it so I
think that will probably be my advice
when we teach people like at the crash
course for instance it's two days and
I'm really I'm really conscious not to
try and just give people loads of
different strategies what how we work is
I will teach something then I'll show
them and I'll actually do it and then
I'll make you do it and you'll do it and
you won't leave until you've got one or
two strategies absolutely nailed so
that's the way I like to teach that's
the way I recommend I hope that's been
helpful if it has don't forget to share
this video leave a comment I'll see you
next time god bless thank you so much
for watching if you benefit just on that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time